hey there and welcome to this ProFlowers
quick tip I am Cameron and today I'm
gonna toot my own horn here for the
analog glitch pack I've got available
over on motion science TV if you haven't
checked out the analog glitch pack it's
a pack that myself and another guy Ryan
fie guard put together to give you
elements that you can use in your motion
design or edits there are really awesome
elements and I want to show you how you
can use them in a really simple way so
what I've got here is the pack is
brought in in part 2 there's part 1 and
part 2 by running part 2 for this
example and I'm just gonna bring in a
few of them just show you how powerful
they are okay so we're gonna bring one
of them in here and we're just going to
drag it in here and we're just going to
preview this
these are 4k elements and this is a 1920
by 1080 comp so you can see just by
bringing in here immediately
right how cool it is alright so we can
kind of see glitch here so let's make
the the type glitch as well so one
changes back to normal go to effect my
favorite way to do this is displacement
mapping select the analog glitch 36 and
then just bump the values way up here so
there you go we've got some interesting
graphic glitching going on can change
this back to soft light if I wanted to
and a little challenging a/c so what
I'll do is I'll just actually bring the
position over just a hair since we've
glitched it to the right there we go and
I'm stupid 8 the layer that's like I'm
pretty dope it's even more dope if I
undo this let me show you a few other
ways you can do some cool stuff here so
I'll change this back to normal I will
turn off the glitch layer here so you
can see just that by itself looks pretty
legit change it from I'm just gonna
replace 36 with 37 you can see it gives
it a little bit different look there
let's try 38 let's bring 38 in let's see
what that looks like even more serious
type collision that's pretty cool as
well something I could do with this
as I could go and I could maybe set like
a keyframe now let's set a keyframe here
let me bring down the amount just a hair
you know something like that go the
beginning here and just crank it way up
something like that so maybe it
transitions on and let's see how that
looks so maybe I set a keyframe I would
make maybe make this do ease in and then
turn on my speed graph here and really
you know that's pretty cool as well like
I said you again you could turn this
back on if you wanted to you could make
this like a soft light an overlay
there's all different ways you could do
this really increase the transparency
maybe bring down the transparency of
this one you get the idea so that is how
you can use the analog glitch elements
I've had a lot of people ask me like how
would you use these things I really am
interested in them but I don't still
know how I'd use them this is just one
very simple example of how you could use
these elements if you like this quick
tip I would invite you to check out pro
flows plus over at motion science TV
we've got lots of techniques trends
workflows techniques that are way more
involved than just this there's in
full-on lessons series of lessons that
teach you things like glitching so I
invite you to check it out that's all I
got for you today